[Music]
now my gum rest
my name is speedbag and welcome to
another sunny noisy afternoon in Italy
well well welcome to I really feel like
everyone is staring at me here in the
neighborhood so I hope it's good again
first off thank you bros for 1 million
nine hundred thousand subscribers I
didn't think we'd hit that many it's
crazy every week I always think like
that gonna grow any more him it always
does somehow so thank you but I still
really appreciate it even though it was
surpassed way more than I ever imagined
but hey next week two million can we do
it can we not Adam maybe you bros always
seem to surprise me so let's see I'm
gonna show where I donate the money so
let's cut the pizza pie in the future
all right so here we are at the donation
page for st. Jude's Children's Research
Hospital they are a great organization
that helps younger people children with
cancer or other diseases together bro
army together we had thirty four
thousand three hundred ninety four dot
$75 this is what we got
I did a breath I'm proud of ya III again
I just want to say thank you both so
much for all all your support in this
charity event I can't tell you enough
how happy I'm about it I keep saying
that the bro army is the best freaking
subscriber base on YouTube and I think
this this really shows that leaves one
of the many reasons why you are so
awesome so many brothers breast men
you should give yourself a pat on the
back you donated $34,000 to charity so
thank you all right they are back with
me Pierre the pie in the pan anyway
we're gonna do a competition there's
gonna be a competition for a bit smaller
channels and it's gonna be done through
the forums this time you can pretty much
find all the information you need in the
first two links in description you'll
find all the rules you'll find how to
enter excellent more precise pretty much
so check that out if you're interested
so I this is actually the third one I
did and it's it's usually a really nice
boost for if you're a small Channel
though the reason why I'm doing this
mostly it's because I keep seeing
comments the top-rated comments are
always self advertising comments it
could be indirect or directly telling
people to watch you know I people
camouflage them pretty well nowadays
because they usually get hated for it I
I want your best to to realize that you
really don't have to self advertise on
other people's videos you don't have to
do giveaways to grow on YouTube you
don't have to collaborate with a big
youtubers everyone is keep asking me
over for shoutouts and stuff like that
and I mean sure I was really lucky with
how I got started on YouTube and I feel
really lucky to be where I am but I
never did any of these things I never
got did exploited the system with
putting in different tags or whatever
people do and all these kind of weird
things just to grow on YouTube or just
to get use I feel like it's definitely
the wrong approach the best tip I can
give you as a youtuber I think I stole
it from Freddie Wong but make videos
because you like making videos the rest
will come by itself and if you don't
make videos because you are enjoying it
then you're just gonna stop making
videos anyway there seems to be an
endless way of thinking that you have to
be famous and you have to make money and
I think that if like I said you know
make videos because you enjoy making
them any other approach is the wrong
I know that's easy for me to say but if
you want you can go back and watch my
older videos actually talk about it and
I say that you know I'm not in it for to
win it I don't know exactly my a hundred
hundred subs video or something like
that I think that was pretty much it
I've been good time for des hell up Eric
hey how you doing let's punch her Brit
no you're not gonna punch you you ready
for this pres say awesome thanks for
your support
you know I love you
[Music]